la recrudescence des quatre convives 19
se poursuit donc en russie où un
confinement partielle de quatre mois
entre en vigueur aujourd'hui à moscou
notamment pour les plus de 60 ans plus
de précision avec notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman presque 38 mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus en russie
ces dernières 24 heures le pays égale
son record du nombre de contaminations
quotidienne quant aux décès et leur
nombre continue de dépasser le millier
par jour le chiffre annoncé de 1069
victimes du coc u19 ce jour au ministère
russe de la santé on affirme que ce taux
de mortalité
particulièrement élevé est dû aux
variants delta le risque de décès ayant
augmenté de 2,3 fois et ce alors que le
pic des contaminations des décès n'a pas
encore été atteint je vous propose
d'écouter à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
aucune raison de penser que le taux
d'incidence du coc vie 19 en russie a
atteint un sommet le niveau de
couverture vaccinale contre la nouvelle
infection à coronavirus est un facteur
clé de l'incidence du coc vie 19
en outre l'augmentation de cet incident
s'est également duo variant du virus
aujourd'hui nous constatons la dominance
du variant delta dussart skov 2 qui est
plus contagieux et une photogénie site
est plus élevé c'est à dire qu'ils se
développent plus rapidement et provoque
des formes plus grave de la maladie il
est donc associé à un risque accru
d'hospitalisations et de décès sur fond
de flambée des chiffres épidémique à
vladimir poutine s'est adressé ce matin
aux responsables régionaux en
recommandant une série de mesures
restrictives qui doivent s'ajouter à la
période chômée afin de contrer la
propagation du virus dont le rpt
confinement pour les personnes de plus
de 60 ans qui ne sont pas vaccinés au
l'interdiction pour les bars et les
restaurants d'accueillir du public entre
23 heures et 6 heures du matin écoutez
vladimir poutine a recommandé aux
régions de donner aux employés deux
jours de congés payés pour se faire
vacciner
d'interdire les spectacles et
divertissements et de limiter la
fourniture de services de restauration
le soir et la nuit
d'interdire pendant la nuit les
divertissements et le fonctionnement des
restaurants
de faire passer les salariés de plus de
60 ans et ceux qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques en télétravail pour quatre
semaines
d'assurer que les personnes non
vaccinées de plus de 60 ans respecte le
régime de confinement de ne laisser
entrer dans certains établissements que
les personnes possédant un certificat de
vaccination ou attestant qu'ils sont
rétablis de la maladie y compris via un
qr code pour rappel le président russe a
dit mir poutine instaurer une période
chômée partout en russie du 30 octobre
au 7 novembre les régions où la
situation épidémiologique et plus graves
peuvent atteindre cette période pour le
dire est qu'elle estime nécessaires